THERE A LOT OF COMEY CITY SO WHY
DON'T WE GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
WOULD YOU LIKE.
START WE'RE GONNA START WITH
FILE ITEM ONE AB SEVEN TWENTY
THREE AND THIS IS REGULAR ORDER
BUSINESS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS EXCITED TO BE
HERE AS YOU ALL KNOW -- IT'S
BEEN REPEATED BY MANY FOLKS
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCING.
A HOUSING CRISIS AND WE MUST
FIND CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS FROM
DISPLACEMENT WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY BUILDING YOUR
HOMES FOR ALL INCOME LEVELS.
IN THE BAY AREA THE CITY OF
OAKLAND A'S BEGIN CONVERTING
THEIR EXISTING RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS INTO AFFORDABLE UNITS.
THIS HAS THE BENEFIT OF
PROTECTING RESIDENTS AND THEIR
HOMES AND IS QUICKER AND LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN BUILDING NEW
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
UNDER EXISTING LAW A TAX
EXEMPTION TO CONVERT TO
BUILDINGS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ONLY APPLIES TO HOUSING.
OCCUPIED BY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS BASED UPON THE
VERIFICATION OF EACH HOUSEHOLD
INCOME.
AB SEVEN TWENTY THREE PROPOSES
TO EXPAND EXISTING LAW AND
PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE PAYMENT FOR
PROPERTIES LEAST TO AND OPERATED
BY A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
WHEN A PROPERTY OWNER CONVERTS
THEIR EXISTING BUILDING TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING?
INITIALLY THE BILL IS NARROWLY.
FOCUSED ON ALAMEDA AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTIES AND HAS A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET.
UNDER THESE PROVISIONS.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE ALAMEDA
ASSESSOR -- AND OTHERS -- TO
WORK THROUGH SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE REYES BUT
ARE COMMITTED TO FINDING A
WORKABLE SOLUTION WITH THEM AND
WE'VE GOT THE CITY OF OPEN HERE.
TO TESTIFY AS WELL WHO IS THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL WE HAVE
SUPPORT BY THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M THERE AND RUN
A LADY ON THE POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR HOUSING SECURITY IN THE
OFFICE OF OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY
SCHAAF.
THE HOUSING CRISIS IS HAVING A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE CITY OF
OAKLAND IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
RENTS HAVE INCREASED 56%.
SALES PRICES HAVE INCREASED 65%.
THIS MEANS THAT MANY LONGTIME
OPENERS CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO
LIVE IN THE CITY AND ARE FORCED
TO LEAVE THE CITY AN INDOOR
HORRENDOUS COMMUTE OR TO LIVE ON
OUR STREETS.
IN RESPONSE THE CITY'S BEEN
TAKING AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO
ADDRESS THIS HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS WE'VE
STREAMLINED HOUSING PRODUCTION.
SO THE LAST THREE YEARS WE'VE
BUILT MORE THAN TEN TIMES THE
NUMBER OF HOUSING UNITS IN THE
PREVIOUS THREE YEARS.
WE'VE ALSO BUILDING MORE
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE'VE INCREASED OUR FOR A
HOUSING IMPACT FEES THE VOTERS
HAVE PASSED LOCALAFFORDABLE
HOUSING BONDS.
AND WE'VE ALSO BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL AT SECURING STATE
FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
WE'RE STILL SHORT ON MEETING OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GOALS AND WE
NEED MORE TOOLS.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED
ONE OF OUR GROWING STRATEGIES IS
TAKING EXISTING.
HOUSING WERE CURRENT TENANTS ARE
PAYING AFFORDABLE RENTS.
AND CONVERTING THAT TO LONG TERM
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THIS IS QUICKER AND CHEAPER THAN
BUILDING NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND IT PROTECTS EXISTING TENANTS
FROM DISPLACEMENT.
WE'VE TALKED TO PROPERTY OWNERS
WHO ARE INTERESTED IN CONVERTING
PROPERTIES INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT THEY NEED A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE.
THIS BILL WOULD INCENTIVIZE
PROPERTY OWNERS TO CONVERT
HOUSING.
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THIS
MANNER.
THANK YOU.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS IN SUPPORT
YES.
EVERY GIRL FROM.
WHEN IS IS IN OPPOSITION?
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE NETWORK.
IN THE ANALYSIS IT ASK THAT YOU
AMEND YOUR BILL TO INCLUDE
CITIES AS WELL AS COUNTIES.
IN THEIR ABILITY TO PAY THIS
AMOUNT.
WILL YOU BE DOING THAT.
YEAH I THINK WE'RE VERY OPEN TO
MINUTES YEP.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THING I WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND WE
HAVE A QUORUM WILL TAKE IT UP
FOR OKAY.
THANK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR FOR
TESTING ONLY ONLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
FOUR IS A BILL THAT WOULD
ADDRESS WHAT IS A MAJOR HOLE IN
OUR STATE'S HOUSING POLICY AND
THAT IS THE PLIGHT OF THE
MISSING MIDDLE.
THE MISSING MIDDLE REFER TO TENS
OF MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
EARN TOO MUCH TO QUALIFY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT ARE
UNABLE TO AFFORD MARKET RATE
HOUSING.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TEACHERS AND
NURSES FIREFIGHTERS AND COPS
HEALTHCARE CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
RETAIL AND SERVICE WORKERS THOSE
WHO WERE CRITICAL TO OUR ECONOMY
WHO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE PLIGHT
OF THE MISSING MIDDLE BY
CREATING A PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION TO CERTAIN MIDDLE
INCOME RENTAL UNITS OFFERED AND
AFFORDABLE RENT TO HOUSEHOLDS
MAKING BETWEEN EIGHTY AND A 120%
OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS AND HOUSING
OPERATORS WHO RECEIVED EXEMPTION
WOULD COMMIT THE FOR SAVINGS TO
REDUCE RENTS FOR MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS 220% BELOW THE FAIR
MARKET RENT FOR AN AREA.
THIS WILL SPUR CONSTRUCTION OF
NEW MODERATE INCOME UNITS AND
ALLOWS TO PRESERVE AND REDUCE
RENTS IN SOME -- IN SOME OF OUR
EXISTING UNITS ON THE MARKET.
I'LL JUST NOTE THIS BILL WILL
NOT DRAW WAY SUBSIDY A RESOURCES
AWAY FROM THE ALREADY LIMITED
POOL OF STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR LOW INCOME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OUR JOINT AUTHORS ON THIS BILL
WHO REPRESENTS SOME OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE RENTAL MARKETS IN THE
STATE HAVE SEEN OUR MIDDLE CLASS
IS BEING HOLLOWED OUT BY THE
HOUSING CRISIS.
HOW FAMILIES ARE PAYING TOO MUCH
IN BEING PUSHED FARTHER AND
FARTHER FROM THEIR JOBS AND WITH
THAT LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESS?
MARINO WHITE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM.
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MARINO WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM -- ARMAND
MEMBERS ARE FOCUSED ON THE
PRODUCTION PRESERVATION OF LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSING AND
BRING TOGETHER EVERYONE THAT IS
INVOLVED IN PUTTING TOGETHER
DEVELOPMENT DEALS.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO MENTION
WERE IN THE MIDST OF A CRUSHING
HOUSING CRISIS WHICH YOU'RE ALL
AWARE OF AND THAT AND WE'VE
HEARD MUCH BOTH FROM THE
GOVERNOR MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
AROUND THE PROBLEM WORD NOW THAT
THE THE HIGH RENTS ARE IMPACTING
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
PRIMARILY AND HIGH COST COUNTIES --
THE STATE IS CONTEMPLATING MANY
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO
INCENTIVIZE THE PRODUCTION OF
RENTAL HOUSING FOR THIS INCOME
BAND AND THIS BILL DOES A VERY
CAREFUL JOB OF THREADING THE
NEEDLE TO ENSURE.
THAT WHAT THE STATE IS DOING
REALLY TARGETS THOSE UNITS IN
THOSE HIGH COST COUNTY SO THAT
WE'RE NOT TAKING AWAY NECESSARY
RESOURCES BOTH FROM LOW INCOME
HOUSING PRODUCTION.
AND ALSO NOT NOT -- SUBSIDIZING
MARKET RATE HOUSING THAT
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN
SOME PARTS OF SEE CAN'T AFFORD --
AND SO FOR THAT REASON WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS MEASURE WE
THINK IT REALLY COMPLEMENTS THE
OTHER EFFORTS THAT WILL PAIR
PERFECTLY WITH WHAT LOCALS ARE
DOING IT TO TO IMPACT THIS
INCOME BAND.
AND WILL ALSO FARE VERY WELL
WITH KELLY TO PHASE MAKES INCOME
LOAN PROGRAM THEY'LL BE SERVING
HOUSEHOLDS MAKING A RANGE OF
INCOMES FROM 30% AM I 210020%
AND MY THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WHEN IS IS IN OPPOSITION?
MADAM CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
PATRICK SABLE HOW SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL REPORT WILL
HOUSING AND WE WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE DOT
QUIRK -- THE ASSESSORS ARE
CONCERNED BOTH ABOUT WORKLOAD
AND ADMINISTRATIVE DIFFICULTIES
YOU WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT TO
THE ON THAT ISSUE -- I HAVE NOT
SEEN THEIR LETTER AT BY I THINK
WHAT IT IS IN THE ANALYSIS IN
THE ANALYSIS WHAT THE BILL DOES
THAT BIG SORT OF CAREFULLY
THREADS THAT NEEDLE IS BY PAYING
A PAIR IS THIS WITH EXISTING
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
PRODUCTION PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
SORT OF A DEED.
RESTRICTION SO I EXPECT MOST THE
TIME THIS THE THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL WILL BE USING KINDS IN
KIND I'M.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM WHERE THERE'S A SIMILAR
MINISTRATION AT THAT THE SENSORS
ARE USED TO DEALING WITH.
I JUST SKIM THROUGH THE LETTER
AND AND SO YOU KNOW I ACTUALLY
JUST REACH OUT TO MY SISTER TO
UNDERSTAND -- THE GIST OF THIS
IN MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IN
OUR CITY -- SHE DOESN'T SHARE
THE PERSPECTIVE OF A FELLOW
SISTERS BUT WE WILL.
UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT THAT I
THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED WAS SAID.
IT IT'S SUGGESTED THAT THERE'S
SOME CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT
CONSTITUTES PROPER RENT
RESTRICTIONS BECAUSE WE HAVE TWO
STANDARDS IN THE BILL ON WHAT
RENT RESTRICTIONS WOULD ENTAIL.
I WILL TELL YOU I PERSONALLY
THINK THAT IT'S CLEAR TO SAY
RENTS AT 20% BELOW FOR MARKET
RENT OR MARKET STUDY THAT'S
PREPARED FOR THAT PARTICULAR
MARKET BUT I AM MORE THAN HAPPY
AGAIN WITH -- THE COMMITTEES --
IF THE COMMITTEES INTERESTED IN
DIVING INTO WHETHER THERE'S
ADDITIONAL CLARITY THAT WE CAN
BUILD INTO WHAT THAT STANDARD IS.
AND WE ARE ENGAGING WITH THE
ASSESSOR TO TRY TO HAVE -- TO
TRY TO DRILL DOWN ON THEIR
CONCERTS.
THANK YOU.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE -- AND
AND FOR THE RECORD MR TO AND I
ARE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BILL THIS WEEK SO
WE WILL HAVE MORE INFORMATION
LATER -- WITH THAT WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE I APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION THE COMMITTEE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE CHAIR --
WOMAN'S -- ATTENTION TO THIS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS RECORDED AT THIS
NO ACTION ON THIS ITEM TODAY BUT
THANK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM. SEVEN AB
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE SHE'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN.
GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM SPEAKER AND A MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE A BILL
WHICH BUILDS ON THE SUCCESS OF
THE CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT OR KELLY I TO SEE.
BY ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS WITH
FEDERAL INDIVIDUAL.
TAX PAYER IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS
ALSO KNOWN AS ITUNES TO QUALIFY
FOR THE CREDIT.
KELLY I TO SEE WAS ELECTED IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AS A
PROGRAM TO HELP LOW EARNING
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES MAKE
ENDS MEET AND TO BUILD TOWARDS
ECONOMIC SECURITY.
MODELED AFTER THE FEDERAL YEAH I
TO SEE KELLY I TO SEE PROVIDES A
REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT TO PEOPLE
WHO QUALIFY.
BASED ON HOW MUCH THEY EARN AND
HOW MANY QUALIFYING CHILDREN
THEY SUPPORT.
THE CREDIT REDUCES POVERTY AND
ENCOURAGES WORK BY ENHANCING THE
CREDIT WITH EACH.
ADDITIONAL DOLLAR OF EARNING A
PERSON MAKES UNTIL REACHING THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT.
WHILE THE FACILITATION
SUBSEQUENT EXPANSION OF KELLY I
TO SEE HAVE BEEN A CRITICAL TO
SUPPORTING WORKING FAMILIES.
IT HAS UNFORTUNATE LEFT OUT ARE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
IMMIGRANTS.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ARE KEY
MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES PAYING BILLIONS
ANNUALLY IN STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES.
HOWEVER IMMIGRANTS A VARYING
STATUS FOR USE ITUNES. FOR TAX
PURPOSES ARE CURRENTLY
INELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
KELLY I TO SEE.
AB FIFTY NINETY THREE PROVIDES
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO INDIVIDUALS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
TO PARTICIPATE IN A CRITICAL
PROGRAM WHICH ALL ELIGIBLE.
WORKING CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN.
BY DOING THIS WE ARE ENSURING
THAT KELLY I. T. SEE WORKS TO
ITS FULL POTENTIAL AND IS TRULY
COMBATING POVERTY.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
YOUR TO TESTIFY.
ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL ARE NO
LALLI SOME THE BOND WITH THE
UNITED WAY CALIFORNIA.
AND SASHA FELDSTEIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NAY
ELLIS ON THE WILD WITH THE NOT
AWAY SO CALIFORNIA.
UNITED WAY FIGHTS FOR THE HEALTH
EDUCATION AND FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF EVERY PERSON IN
EVERY COMMUNITY AND TO THAT END
WE'RE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB.
FIFTY NINETY THREE EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE ECONOMIC SECURITY IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN EVERY EVERYONE
SHOULD KNOW HOW HARD WORK PAYS
OFF HOWEVER WITHOUT ENSURING
THAT ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS WHO WORK PAY AND
FILE TAXES.
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE CALLIE I TO
SEE WE CANNOT FULFILL THIS
MISSION OF ECONOMIC JUSTICE FOR
ALL.
LAST YEAR I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY%
TO BE A VOLUNTEER TAX PREPARER
AND CINEMA COUNTY.
IT WAS TRULY REWARDING TO HELP
FAMILIES CLAIM THE YEAH I TO SEE
ANOTHER CREDITS WHICH CLEARLY
PUT MORE MONEY IN THEIR POCKET
SPECIALLY FOR MANY WHO HAD BEEN
AFFECTED BY THE CINEMA FIRES.
AND EXPERIENCE JOB LOSS AND LOSS
WAGES DUE TO THIS THE FASTER.
AT THE SAME TIME I SAW HER
WORKING FAMILIES DESPITE BEING
INCOME ELIGIBLE -- FOR THE EITC
COULDN'T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT
BECAUSE THEY FILED WITH THE
NIGHT.
TEN THESE FAMILIES WERE NO
DIFFERENT FROM ANY OTHER
HARDWORKING FAMILY TRYING TO GET
AHEAD HEAD AND BUILD A BRIGHT
FUTURE THEY SIMPLY FILED WITH
THE NIGHT.
TEN POLICE ALREADY IDENTIFIED
FOR THE PURPOSE OF FILING AND
PAYING THEIR TAXES SO THERE'S NO
REASON THAT.
THEY SHOULD BE EXCLUDED FROM
THIS CRITICAL CREDIT.
A THIS EXCLUSION IS MOST HARPER
HARMFUL WHEN YOU CONSIDER THAT
IF ONE PARENT IN THE HOUSEHOLD.
FILING HAS A NIGHT TEN THE
ENTIRE FAMILY MISSES OUT ON THE
CREDIT INCLUDING CITIZEN
CHILDREN.
IN FACT THE NEST THE MADE IT 74%
OF HOUSEHOLDS THAT WOULD BENEFIT
FROM INCLUDING AYE TEN FILERS IN
THE KELLY I TO SEE LIVE IN
HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT EIGHT OUT OF
TEN FAMILIES LIVING IN POVERTY
ARE ACTUALLY WORKING FAMILIES
AND THOSE WHO WOULD BENEFIT FROM
AB FIFTY NINETY THREE ARE
PRIMARILY FARMWORKERS
HOUSEKEEPING CLEANERS COOKS.
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS JANITORS
THAN MAINTENANCE WORKERS.
MOST OF ALL THEY'RE PART OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE FAMILIES NO
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE IN POVERTY
NO FAMILY SHOULD LIVE IN PART
POVERTY AND MOST IMPORTANTLY NO
CHILD WHO LIVE AND PARTLY.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE TOO YOU'RE
ABLE ON AB.
FIFTY NINETY THREE THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS SASHA FELL FIFTEEN
I'M A POLICY ANALYST AT THE CAN.
AT THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER HI MY NAME IS
SASHA FELT STEEN.
WE ARE A STATE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
ADVANCE INCLUSIVE POLICIES.
OKAY JUST PULL IT ALL JUST GET
OUT MY BACK TO YOU THEN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ARE WE ARE STAY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
ADVANCE INCLUSIVE POLICIES FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO EQUITY AND
INCLUSION FOR ALL IMMIGRANTS TO
BE ABLE TO LEARN WORK AND THRIVE
IN OUR STATE'S ECONOMY.
WE ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE THE EITC
HAS DONE MORE THAN ANY OTHER
PROGRAM TO LIFT FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY.
RESEARCH AND EVALUATIONS HAVE
SHOWN THAT THE EITC PROMOTES
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS.
BOOST LOCAL ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
MOST IMPORTANT IMPROVES CHILD
AND MATERNAL HEALTH.
IT IS FULLY IN LINE WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE LIFTING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY TASK FORCE REPORT WHICH
ACKNOWLEDGES THE POVERTY
FIGHTING A FAX OF CALLIE IDC.
WE KNOW THE IMMIGRANTS
CONTRIBUTE ONE THIRD OF
CALIFORNIANS GDP AND ARE VITAL
TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
AND WE KNOW THE IMMIGRANTS MAKE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
STATE AND LOCAL REVENUES
INCLUDING UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS.
YET THOUSANDS OF WORKING
IMMIGRANT HOUSEHOLDS WITH A
RANGE OF IMMIGRATION STATUS AS
ARE CURRENTLY EXCLUDED FROM
ACCESSING CALLIE ITC SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY USE AND I TEN THE
EXCLUSION ALSO HARMS THOSE WHO
HAVE A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
BUT LOSE THEIR DOCTOR OR TPS
STATUS.
THIS EXCLUSION NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS ADULTS AND CHILDREN
ALIKE AS MANY IMMIGRANTS LIVING
MAKE STATUS HOUSEHOLDS WITH U.
S. CITIZEN CHILDREN WHO MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THE
CALLIE IDC SIMPLY BECAUSE OF
THEIR PARENTS IMMIGRATION STATUS.
I'VE EXPRESSED TO YOU BEFORE HOW
ARE COMMUNITIES ON THE GROUND
DEEPLY UNDERSTAND HOW A MODEST
TAX CREDIT COULD SOMETIMES MEAN
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PAYING
FOR BASIC NEEDS.
SUCH AS MEDICAL EXPENSES A
CHILD'S EDUCATION OR SAVING FOR
RETIREMENT OR NOT.
SO I WANT TO MAKE A FEW THINGS
CLEAR ONE THE BENEFITS OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANT.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET AND POLICY CENTER
INCLUDING AYE TEN FILERS IN THE
CURRENT CALLIE IDC WOULD BENEFIT
FROM A HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND TO TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND MORE
HOUSEHOLDS WHO ARE WORKING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. TO INCLUDING AYE
TEN FILERS TARGETS CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENTS IN FIGHTING POVERTY
TO LOW INCOME WORKERS OF COLOR.
98% OF INDIVIDUALS AND 97% OF
CHILDREN WHO WOULD BENEFIT FROM
INCLUDING AYE TEN FILERS ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THREE INCLUDING
AYE TEN FILERS TARGETS
HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN.
A SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY 74% OF
HOUSEHOLDS THAT WOULD BENEFIT
FROM INCLUDING AYE TEN FILERS IN
THE CURRENT CALLIE I TO SEE OUR
HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN.
THOUSANDS OF WHOM ARE CHILDREN
UNDER.
SIX AB FIFTEEN NINETY THREE BY
REMOVING THE EXCLUSION FOR AYE
TEN FILERS MAKES ECONOMIC SENSE
IS BASED ON SOUND RESEARCH THAT
SUPPORTS ITS EFFICACY BUT MOST
IMPORTANT IT WOULD ENSURE THAT
OUR STATE'S INVESTMENTS IN
FIGHTING POVERTY WORK TO FIGHT
POVERTY FOR EVERY CALIFORNIAN.
THEREFORE WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SUPPORT EIGHTY FIFTEEN
NINETY THREE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR A VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM -- AS
I WHEN CAN YOU.
TAKE THE ROLE [inaudible]
BURKE HERE.
WROTE TO GRAY MAYES [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK HERE.
REVERSE.
TING [inaudible]
THERE.
YEAH OF COURSE THANK YOU
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DESCHANEL ON CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND A CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS THANKS.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEJANDRO DOWN
HERE ON BEHALF OF NEXT AND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS CUT THE MUSTARD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
POLICY ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
LINDA WATER WITH CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI MY CAL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
TERRY ONLY ECONOMIC SECURITY
PROJECT ACTION IN SUPPORT.
JACKIE LONG WITH GRACE AND TELL
PARTY WE ARE BEING CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT -- THIS
PAIRS WELL WITH A TIRED A CHILD
TAX CREDIT TO ADDRESS THE
POVERTY.
KEVIN'S GO CALIFORNIA INTERFAITH
COALITION WHICH INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH
WOMEN.
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS THE LUTHERAN OFFICE OF
PUBLIC POLICY.
THE JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE OF CALIFORNIA GRACE
AND CALIFORNIA CHURCH IMPACT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible] ONE OF I DON'T ENVY
YOU TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND IT LET ME
PREFACE BY SAYING WE WE DON'T
OBJECT AT ALL TO THE GOALS THAT
ARE TRYING TO BE ACHIEVED THEIR
EXTREMELY MERITORIOUS AND WE
THINK THAT CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
CAN BE PUT TOGETHER. TO MAKE
SURE THAT ADEQUATE FUNDING AND
SUPPORT IS PROVIDED THE REASON
THAT WERE OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE
IN ITS CURRENT FORM YOU'LL BE
GETTING A NUMBER OF OTHER OPPOSE
LETTERS IF ON OTHER TAX CREDITS --
VERY SHORTLY -- TAX CREDIT TO DO
BECAUSE COST MONEY AND FORTY
CENTS OF EVERY TAX CREDIT THAT
IS CREATED ACTUALLY WOULD BE
MONEY THAT OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
GONE TO PROP NINETY EIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS.
SO IT IS ACTUALLY DIVERTING
MONEY THAT WOULD HELP SCHOOLS
56% OF OUR CHILDREN ON OUR
SCHOOLS ARE IN PRE REDUCE LUNCH
SO WE ARE ALREADY.
MAKING SHORT -- WE'RE HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME MAKING SURE THAT
WE CAN ADEQUATELY MEET THE NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS AND THESE ISSUES
ARE ARE BECOMING.
MORE COMPLICATED THAT THE LOCAL
LEVEL YOU'RE WE'RE HEARING A LOT
MORE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT --
POSSIBLE SCRIPT STRIKES BECAUSE
EDUCATION FUNDING HAS NOT BEEN
ADEQUATE FOR SO LONG AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS IT'S BECOMING
MORE TENSE -- WE HAVE ASKED --
FOR A MORATORIUM ESSENTIALLY ON
TAX CREDITS IN TILL THERE CAN BE
AN ADEQUATE EVALUATION OF ALL OF
THE EXISTING TAX CREDITS THAT
ARE ON THE BOOKS WE LOOKED AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
EXPENDITURES FOR THE LAST DECADE.
ON THE LAST DECADE CALIFORNIA
PAID OUT OVER FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN TAX CREDITS DURING
THAT SAME DECADE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT WHICH FUNDS
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS I HAD SIXTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS REDUCE WE
LOST OVER.
THIRTY THOUSAND TEACHING
POSITIONS AND AS YOU MANY OF YOU
THAT HAVE CHILDREN NO THAT THAT
AMOUNT OF SERVICES THAT WERE
PROVIDED IN SCHOOLS WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED SO WE
WOULD LIKE.
TO STRONGLY ENCOURAGE OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE TO FIND
AN ALTERNATIVE FUNDING MECHANISM
FOR THE BILL BY EITHER LOOKING
AT EXISTING TAX CREDITS THAT
MIGHT NOT BE MEETING THE THE
GOALS THEY WERE INTENDED TO IT.
TO PROVIDE TO LOOK AT TRYING TO
FIND SOME OF THOSE REVENUES TO
REPLACE THIS WAY WE'RE NOT
ADDING ON TO THE FUNDING THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN DIVERTED FROM
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND IF THAT
COULD HAPPEN WE WOULD BE MORE
THAN WILLING TO HELP TO FIND AN
ADEQUATE PATH FORWARD BECAUSE WE
DO.
BELIEVE THAT THE I. T. C. IS
VERY MERITORIOUS WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T COME ON THE
BACK TO KIDS BECAUSE WE
ABSOLUTELY KNOW THAT THE INTENT
IS NOT.
TO TAKE MORE FROM CHILDREN.
ADDITIONAL WHEN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YEAH I HAVE A COUPLE AYE TO AND
I'M NOT SURE I'M LOOKING AT THE
REPUBLICAN ANALYSIS HERE AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THIS IS
CORRECT IT SAYS THIS CURRENT
PROGRAM IS EXPECTED TO COST FOUR
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
IS THAT IS THAT ACCURATE.
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE TOTAL COSTS IN
IT BUT IF IT'S NOT IT'S NOT NOT
WRITTEN GREAT HERE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S WHAT THE
TOTAL COST OF OF THIS.
THAT IS ONE OF THE ESTIMATES
THAT'S PROVIDED OKAY.
AND THEN.
I'VE BEEN A BIG FAN OF THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT -- IN
FACT IF YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY
OF THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT --
IT IT WAS -- A REPUBLICAN IDEA
MIGHT CONCEPT -- IS IS THAT IF
YOU GET PEOPLE WORKING AND YOU
GET THEM TO BE PRODUCTIVE ANY
BEGIN SET OF EYES -- THAT THAT
WORK AND THEN AT SOME POINT IN
TIME THEY'LL BE ENOUGH RESOURCES
WHERE THEY WOULD NEED ANYMORE A
GOVERNMENTAL.
ASSISTANCE -- I THINK THAT
THAT'S A A LAUDABLE GOAL.
I'M I'M THINKING -- IN MY HEAD
IN REGARDS TO TO THIS.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION STATUS BECAUSE -- IF
IF YOU'VE GOT INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE HERE.
WHETHER THEY ARE BOMB DOCUMENTED
OR UNDOCUMENTED BUT THEY DO NOT
HAVE A SOUL SECURITY HOW DO WE
KNOW HOW LONG THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE.
IN THIS COUNTRY ARE THEY GOING
TO BE HERE FOR ONE YEAR TWO
YEARS THREE YEARS FIVE YEARS OF
THE INTEND TO STAY.
AND SO PART OF THIS WHEN YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT THE COST OF THIS
THIS PROGRAM -- IS IT IS IT AT
SOME POINT IN TIME YOU HAVE TO
START A FACTOR THESE OTHER THESE
OTHER THINGS AND AND SO I'M JUST
WONDERING IF ANY -- ANALYSIS HAS
BEEN DONE THAT IF WE WERE GOING
TO BE -- SPENDING FOUR HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS IF THERE
IS GOING TO BE A RETURN ON ON
THAT INVESTMENT.
CLEARLY I THINK THE RETURN ON
THE INVESTMENT IS THE WORK.
OR THE TAXES THAT ARE BEING PAID
BY THE IMMIGRANTS -- THATWOULD
BE ONE OF THEM -- ONE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOW LONG THEY'RE
GOING TO STAY I'M NOT SURE.
IF I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT WE HAVE
ASKED HOW LONG THEY'RE GOING TO
SUPPORT AND THE REASON I I SAY
THAT IS THIS IS NOT A NORMAL TAX
CREDIT THIS IS A REFUNDABLE
CREDIT.
WHICH MEANS IT'S A CREDIT YOU
KNOW IF YOUR TAXABLE IF YOU'RE
TO TAX THE TAX CONSEQUENCES WERE
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS YOU COULD
GET A CREDIT OF FIVE OR SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
SO IT'S ACTUALLY MORE THAN WHAT
YOU'D BE PAYING AND FOR TAXES SO
PART OF THAT AGAIN IS AN
INCENTIVE TO TRY TO GET FOLKS TO
BE ABLE. TO TO WORK -- AND SO
THERE'S THERE HAS TO BE SOME
SORT OF QUANTITATIVE ANALYSIS
DONE HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INTENT OF THIS PROGRAM -- IS IS
IS GOING TOWARDS -- THAT THE
ULTIMATE GOAL.
IF I MAY UM SO THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ESTIMATE OF THE
COST IS FOR THE CURRENT KILEY
ITC STRUCTURE.
THERE HAVE BEEN ESTIMATES MADE
ABOUT THE COST OF INCLUDE
REMOVING THE EXCLUSION FOR AYE
TEN FILERS THAT'S ACTUALLY A
RELATIVELY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
THE TOTAL COST OF KELLY I. T. C..
SO THAT'S ONE THING THE SECOND
THING IS THAT I I TEN NUMBERS
ARE RENEWABLE SO IT'S NOT LIKE
YOU ARE AND I TEN FILER AND YOU
HAVE THAT I TO NUMBER
NECESSARILY FOR YOUR WHOLE LIFE.
AS YOU NATURALIZE AND BECOME A
CITIZEN AND GET A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER YOU CAN USE THAT
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER TO FILE
YOUR TAXES BUT IT IS A RENEWABLE
NUMBER SO IT'S NOT AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT GETS EVALUATED.
BUT OF THOSE I TO THOSE FOLKS
WILL BE FILING WITH AN AYE TEN
NUMBER HOW MANY OF THEM END UP
STAYING IN THIS -- STAYING IN
THE COUNTRY AND BECOME
NATURALIZED.
I DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
FOR YOU BUT OKAY.
I DO THINK THERE IS SOME
RESEARCH THEY NAME THE AVERAGE
STAY OF PEOPLE -- YOU KNOW
IMMIGRANTS AND CALIFORNIA'S SO
I'D BE HAPPY TO YOU KNOW RETURN
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION TO TO
YOUR OFFICE.
I WOULD ALSO JUST ADD THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF IMMIGRANTS AND
AND THERE'S A STUDY THAT I CAN
SHARE ON THE NUMBER OF
IMMIGRANTS WERE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE TO NATURALIZE FOR
CITIZENSHIP.
BUT HAVING DONE SO FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS -- SO THEY'RE
ACTUALLY PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
TO BE AND THIS COUNTRY AND SAY
HERE BUT HAVING GONE THROUGH
THAT PROCESS YET.
GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MANAGER.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THE DARK QUIRK
[inaudible]
SO.
I HEARD WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE
ITN HOWEVER -- THE F. T. B. SAYS
WITHOUT A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
IT WILL FIND IN THAT IT'LL HAVE
A GREAT DEAL.
OF DIFFICULTY VERIFYING TAX PAY
REPORTED WAGE WITHHOLDING
INFORMATION.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF IMPROPER
CLAIMS BY ACCIDENT OR PERHAPS
FRAUDULENTLY.
I WOULD YOU CARE -- TO PERHAPS
EDUCATE US ON THAT POINT.
I'D LIKE TO JUST SHARE WITH YOU
THAT -- WHO WOULD I DO FEEL
CONFIDENT THEIR SYSTEM COULD BE
CREATED TO SERVE?
THE UNDOCUMENTED TAXPAYERS
CURRENTLY THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD HAS FOUND WAYS DESPITE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO IDENTIFY
AND TRACK SELF EMPLOYED WORKERS
ALTHOUGH THE INITIAL BARRIERS TO
DO SO WERE THOUGHT TO BE TOO
STEEP.
IN ADDITION THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD IDENTIFIES CURRENT AYE
TEEN FILERS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
FILING AND COLLECTING TAXES.
SO WOULD BE EQUITABLE TO WORK TO
FIND WAYS FOR THEM TO BENEFIT
FROM TAX CREDITS AS WELL.
IF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TAKE
MONEY FROM FOLKS AND IDENTIFY
THEM FOR SOME TAX PURPOSES.
I THINK WE DO HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO FIND PATHWAYS
FOR THEM TO ACCESS A TAX CREDIT.
MEANT TO BRING CALIFORNIANS OUT
OF POVERTY YEAH I JUST SUGGEST
THAT YOU TAKE THE TIME OR YOUR
STAFF TAKE THE TIME TO GO OVER.
AND TALK TO THEM ABOUT IT AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANYTHING YOU CAN
DO AND THE BAIL TO RELIEVE THEIR
CONCERNS VERY GOOD THANK YOU
DOCTOR THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS CONCERNS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL OBVIOUSLY -- LEAVING
POVERTY IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TO ME AND AND THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
SOCIETY CONTRIBUTING TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND LIFTING THESE FAMILIES ON
THESE CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY OR
JUST JUST AS IMPORTANT AS THOSE
WITH SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
TO LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN YOU ALL BRING IT OUT OF THE
INFORMATIONAL SESSION -- BUT
RIGHT.
THIS IS A WHOLE NEW PROCESS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BUT ON THAT NOTE WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
OKAY MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE AB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE AND MOVE THE
BILL.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
THIS TIME I WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PATH TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HOUSING
BURKE HI BURKE ON A BRO.
ROLL RHU.
GRAY MAYES.
MAYES ON MELINDA'S MOLEN.
WHEN I PATRICK NORRIS QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE REAVIS?
REAVIS AYE TING.
THE BILL IS AL.
MOVING A FILE ITEM NINE AB.
THIRTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS DRIVE
EMOTION.
SO MOVED AND SECOND [inaudible]
THREE OF US SECONDS.
I WAS HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE HI BURKE MY BRO.
ROLL AYE CHU GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES ONLINE MELINDA'S SMOLAN.
MULLIN I PATRICK NORRIS WORK I
WORK OUR AYE REAVIS REAVIS AYE
TING.
THE BILL IS OUT AS WELL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TEN AB ONE
FIFTY TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
PROMOTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A MAIN.
SEVEN IS HIGHLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BURKE NINE BURKE AYE BRO.
ROLL AYE CHU GRAY.
MAYES MAYES I'M MELINDA.
MOLEN.
MULLIN ON A PATRON NORRIS QUIRK
NO WORK NO REAVIS.
RIVERS ARE A TEAM.
THE BILL CALLS AT THOSE ON CALL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB --
TWO THIRTY FOUR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS A APPROPRIATIONS AND
LOOKING FOR A MOTION AND A
SECOND SO MOVED.
MS HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE AYE BURKE AYE BRO ROLL AYE
CHIU [inaudible]
GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES HI MELINDA THIS.
MULLIN.
MULLIN I COUNTRY NORRIS.
QUIRK HI BURKE I REAVIS
REAVIS AHRI TING.
YOU WANT TO JUST MOVE.
FILE A MOVING OF EARLY.
WE'RE ON TWELVE WHEN CUT OUT
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB TWO FIFTY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS A TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- WE GO THIS
TIME PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
AHRI BRO.
WELL I CHU.
GRAY.
MAYES MAYES I'M MELINDA THIS
MULLIN.
MULLIN I COUNTRY NORRIS QUIRK NO
WORK NO REAVIS.
REVERSE ALL WRITING.
THE BILL SO CALLED.
DOUBLES ON CALL.
MOVING A FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB --
TWO EIGHTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
TO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MS HIGHLAND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS BURKE
FINE BURKE AYE BRO.
ROLL ARCH YOU.
GRAY MAYES.
MAYES ON MELINDA'S.
MOLEN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE NORRIS QUIRK
AYE QUIRK AYE REAVIS REAVIS HIGH
TING.
A BILL THAT BILL IS OUT.
MEANWHILE I AM FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE OH EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS OF MOTION
AND A SECOND [inaudible]
SO MOVED.
MS SILENT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AHRI BRO.
REAL AYE CHU.
GRAY MAYES.
MAYES I'M MELINDA'S MOLEN. ONE I
PATRICK NORRIS QUIRK I WORK OUR
AYE REAVIS.
REAVIS AYE TING THE BILL SO.
THAT BILLS OUT MOVING A FILE AND
FIFTEEN AB THREE TWENTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED PROCREATION.
THEN OCEAN IN A SECOND SO MOVED.
AND WE GO THANK YOU MISS SILENT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE EYEING
BURKE I'M ROLE.
ROLL AYE CHU GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES ISLANDERS.
MULLIN.
MULLIN ONLINE COUNTRY NORRIS
QUIRK HI WORK OUR I REAVIS.
REAVIS ALL WRITING.
THAT BILLS OUT THAT BUILD OUT.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB SIX OH
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SO MOVED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE OUR AYE BRO BRO ARE YOU.
TO GRAY.
MAYES MAYES ARI MELINDA'S SMOLAN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE NORRIS QUIRK I
WORK OUR AYE REAVIS.
REAVIS ALL WRITING.
THAT BILLS OUT.
RIGHT WHERE I SEVENTEEN MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
SIX FOURTEEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASTOR PROTECTION PROMOTION AND
A IS HIGHLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS O PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE I
BROIL.
GRILL ARE YOU CHU GRAY MAYES.
MAYES I'M LINDA THIS FALLEN.
MULLIN I PATRICK NORRIS QUIRK
ART WORK OF A REAVIS REAVIS I
EIGHTEEN THAT BILLS OUT.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
SEVEN THIRTY SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SO
MOVED.
THANK YOU MISS HOLLY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE HI BURKE ARE YOU BRO.
ROLL I TO GRAY MAYES.
MAYES ONLINE MELINDA'S MOLEN.
MULLIN I HAD THREE NORRIS QUIRK
HI QUIRK OF AYE REAVIS.
RIVERSIDE CHIANG.
SO.
THAT ITEM IS OUT MOVING TO FILE
ITEM NINETEEN AB.
EIGHT THIRTY TWO THE MOTION IS
THE SECOND HOUSING THANK YOU
THIS ITEM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HOUSING.
BURKE ALL RIGHT BURKE ARE YOU
BRO.
ROLL EYES TO GRAY MAYES.
MAYES I'M LINDA THIS MULLIN.
MOON AYE COUNTRY NORRIS QUIRK
ALL RIGHT -- I READ THIS.
WITH THIS ALL RIGHT SEEING.
THE BILL IS OUT AND I WAS THE
LAST OF THE ITEMS ARE VOTING ON
TODAY WE HAVE MEANT WE HAVE
SOMEONE COUNT.
WE LIVE IN A FILE ITEM. TWENTY I
DON'T HAVE THAT ON HERE.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY AB.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE SO MOVED.
TO PASS BY THE APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE HI BURKE I RO.
ROW ARE TO GRAY MAYES.
MAYES I'M LINDA THIS.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE NORRIS QUIRK
ALL RIGHT BURKE AYE REAVIS
REVIEWS ARE.
EIGHTEEN THAT BILL IS OUT NOW
THAT IS THE LAST BILL.
TODAY MOVING TO BACK TO
TESTIMONY ONLY -- SALAS -- WOMEN
FILE ITEM FIVE AB TWELVE FIFTY
EIGHT THIS SALAS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS A PRESENT
BEFORE YOUR SOMEBODY WILL TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHT TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT
WOULD BE THE FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
CALIFORNIA SERVICE MEMBERS AND
VETERANS BAGS OF EXEMPTING
INCOME TAX FROM ACTIVE DUTY PAY.
AND FROM RETIREMENT PAY FOR THE
CUMULATIVE TIME OF ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE AFTER SERVICE MEMBERS
HONORABLY DISCHARGED OTHER BEEN
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL ON MARCH
TWENTY FIFTH WE DID.
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE AMENDMENTS
DRESSED IN THE ANALYSIS I'D LIKE
TO NOTIFY THE TURN THE MEMBERS.
THAT AMENDMENTS ARE BEING
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
WILL SPECIFY THAT THE INCOME TAX
EXEMPTIONS WALLY APPLIED ACTIVE
DUTY PAY.
AND RETIREMENT PAY AND NOT ALSO
INCOME -- SOURCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MEANING THESE FOR CAL
AYE JANA I AM WITH REAP
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS OR FIRM
REPRESENTS THE AMERICAN GI FORUM
OF CALIFORNIA AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA --
BATES DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS.
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL THE NATIONAL
GUARD ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
IN VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL ALL OF
WHICH ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT THE BILL WILL
HELP THE BETTERING GROUPS WERE
REPRESENTED BY EXEMPTING INCOME
TAX FROM ACTIVE DUTY PAY AND
FROM RETIREMENT PAY. FOR THAT Q.
MILITANTS TIME OFF ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE AFTER A SERVICE MEMBER
HAS BEEN HONORABLY DISCHARGED.
THIS BILL WILL HELP VETERANS WHO
MEET BE STRUGGLING FINANCIALLY
AND WILL ALSO REWARD THOSE WHO
HAVE SERVED.
THEIR COUNTRY.
AB TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN A TIME
WHERE WE ARE SEEN VETERANS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
HOMELESSNESS.
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
WE SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION
WHICH WILL ENCOURAGE ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBERS TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA UPON DISCHARGE AND
WILL HELP THOUSANDS OF VETERANS
WHO MIGHT BE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY.
THIS INCOME TAX EXEMPTION WILL
HELP ACTIVE DUTY MEMBERS AND
VETERANS WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING
TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
AND WILL ALSO SERVE AS AN
INCENTIVE FOR MORE SERVICE
MEMBERS TO REMAIN IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND WE'RE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BOAT WHEN THE COMMITTEE
RECKON BEGINS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WHEN IT IS IN OPPOSITION?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COURT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION -- AS IS THE CASE
WITH MANY BILLS OF THIS NATURE
WHILE PLEASE CONSIDER TO BE
MERITORIOUS IN A VARIETY OF WAYS
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS -- IN
PARTICULAR -- THE MEASURE SEEKS
TO PROVIDE AND IT TAX
EXPENDITURE AN EXEMPTION
ESSENTIALLY -- FOR VETERANS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INCOME
STATUS SO EVEN THOSE WHO HAVE NO
NEED TO NECESSARILY BENEFIT FROM
SUCH.
A BENEFIT WOULD IN FACT RECEIVED
QUITE A GENEROUS CREDIT -- IN
ADDITION WE BELIEVE THAT
VETERANS IN THE STATE PARTICULAR
THOSE WHO ARE CERTAINLY HOMELESS
AND IN NEED OF SERVICES WOULD BE
BETTER SERVED BY.
A TARGETED PROGRAM A GRANT OR A
DIRECT EXPENDITURE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE DO OPPOSE THE BILL AS
WRITTEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS FOR THE COMMITTEE.
BURKE FROM JUST TO SAY I AGREE
WITH THE OPPOSITION BUT PERHAPS
YOU CAN CONVINCE ME OTHERWISE
BUT I HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS.
YEAH AND THOSE WERE -- THROUGH
THE CHAIR THOSE WERE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE WERE OPEN TO CLARIFY
WITHIN MINUTES OR SUBMITTED TO
TRY TO NARROW THE COST.
OR LOOKING AT DISHONORABLE
DISCHARGES BUT ALSO LOOKING AT
ONLY THEIR ACTIVE DUTY PAY AND
ALSO.
THE RETIREMENT PAY SO YOU'RE
ACTUALLY LIMITING IT TO ONLY
THAT TYPE OF INCOME AND NOT ALL
INCOME.
AND SO WE WERE MINDFUL OF THE
EXPENSES AND SO THIS IS ONE WE
WERE DOING IT WE'RE TRYING TO
COME UP -- WHAT WITH THE WAY AS
HOW CAN WE HONOR VETERANS AND
ONE OF THE?
MECHANISMS WE CAME ABOUT IS LIKE
WELL IF YOU SERVE FOR FOUR YEARS
AND MAYBE WE CAN GIVE YOU THIS
CREDIT FOR FOUR YEARS IF YOUR
HONOR PLEASE DESTRUCTION ONLY ON
ACTIVE DUTY PAY.
AND YOUR RETIREMENT PAY SO THEN
IT WHAT IT DOES IS IT.
IT BRINGS ACOSTA ACT AND SO
THOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH -- THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE WITH AS WELL GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHATEVER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE WE
APPRECIATE IT WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE WHEN IT
COMES IN I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
WAY FOR US TO HONOR OUR VETERANS
ESPECIALLY -- WITH THE COST
CONSTRAINTS IN IN PLACE I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD MEASURE BALANCED
APPROACH IN.
BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MOVING THE FILE ITEM TWO A. B.
TWO SIXTY SIX FOR TESTIMONY ONLY.
MR CHOI DOCTOR CHOI
.
I HAVE TO BE HONEST.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MOM CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
MEDIA.
NOT PRESENT THE A. B. TWO SIX
SIX FIRST -- DECIDE AB OUT TO A
SIX SIX IS TO OFFER A TAX
INCENTIVE FOR AND THE CREDIT. TO
HOMEOWNERS SO TO OFFSET.
THE PURCHASE AND THE
INSTALLATION OFTEN ATTIC FAN
KROLL SHOW SYSTEMS.
OF FOR THE HOME IN ORDER TO
PREVENT.
THE SPREAD OFF OFF REST AND
SHELTER FIRES.
AB TOOL SIX SIX ARE ON HOW
REDUCE FIRES FROM SPREADING TO
RESIDENTIAL HOMES SO DURING THE
WILD FIRE.
BY PROVIDING A TAX CREDIT OF UP
TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS OF FOR
THE PURCHASE AND INSTALLATION
OFTEN AND EXPAND THE CLOSURES.
THIS ADDED MANTA GROCERS ARE CAN
PREVENT THE FIRES FROM SPREADING
INTO HOMES UP BY BLOCKING FLYING
EMBERS FROM ENTERING THE HIGHLY.
COMBUSTIBLE.
MATERIALS SAW IN RESIDENTIAL AT
X..
CAL FIRE.
REPORTS THAT THE THIS SIMPLE
INSTALLATION IS -- A RESIDENTIAL.
IN A RESIDENTIAL HOME CAN REDUCE
THE SPREAD OF FIRE SO TO OUR OR
ESSENTIAL HOME BY 95%.
AND THE HAS IT EVEN LISTED.
APPROVED THE VENDORS SO ON THE
WEBSITE. FOR HOMEOWNERS. TO
REFERENCE -- IN RESEARCHING
THESE VAN TO CAUTIOUS.
THIS JOURNAL CALIFORNIA HAS
FACED A NUMBER OF FIRES SO UP
AND DOWN THE STATE IN RECENT
YEARS.
AND THIS FILE YES I HAVE A
DIRECTLY IMPACTED THESE STATE
SINCE. TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WITH
THE OVER [inaudible] THIRTY
THOUSAND STRUCTURE DESTROYED AND
OVER THREE MILLION ACRES BURNED
AND ALTHOUGH HUNDRED THE LIVES
LOST.
IN ANALYZING THE SPREAD ALL OF
FIVE YEARS.
MANY OF FIRE CHIEF A HAVE
CONDUCTED CONCLUDED THAT.
AT EXPENSE.
LARA THE PRIMARY IGNITION SOURCE
SIGN IN THE SPREAD OF FIRE
SOFTBALL HOME FROM FIRE EMBERS
ENTERING THROUGH THE ATTIC FANS.
SEVERAL FIRE CHIEFS.
HAVE A STATED THAT THE FAIRLY
SIMPLE WAY TO PREVENT THE FIRES
OF FROM DESTROYING HOMES IS SO
TO INSTALL ATTIC FAN A CRUCIAL
SYSTEM.
WELL FOR A FAIR PRICE THERE ARE
SOME VENDORS SO WE CAN INSTALL
ATTIC VENTS.
CLOSURE SYSTEMS SAW ON HOMES OUT
WITH.
OUR WHICH WAR NOT BILL WITH US
SUCH CROSSED GROCERS.
ACCORDING TO THE OUR FIRE CHIEFS.
THAT ARE -- THAT THE WE HAVE MET
THE OF THESE THE ATTIC FANS SO
GROCERS SYSTEM ARE OVER 95%
EFFECTIVE AT THE KEEPING.
FIRE EMBERS SAW OUT OF THE HOME.
THIS TAX INCENTIVE IT IS SO
SMALL A SMART INVESTMENT IN
ORDER -- TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE
AND THE HOMES OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL HAS CELL WIDESPREAD
THE SUPPORT AND IS A SUPPORTER
BY ORANGE COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY US
ASSOCIATION.
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES A
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION FIRED DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA OR
STATE INSURANCE -- AND THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN KEEPING OUR
STATE AND THE HOMES AS A FOR BY
PER PREVENTING SPREAD OF THE
FIRES.
THANK YOU IN THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE ALSO INSURANCE IN
SUPPORT.
CHARLES SORRY WITH LEGAL
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL URGES -- ENCOURAGES --
GOOD HOMEOWNERSHIP PRACTICES AND
WE ARE SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SMITH ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION -- WE CERTAINLY
AGREE THIS MAY BE A VERY
IMPORTANT WAY TO PROTECT THE
HOME HOWEVER -- DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT WHETHER AS A MATTER OF TAX
PUBLIC POLICY THIS IS A GOOD
CONCEPT AND WOULD IN FACT BE
INCENTIVIZING SOMETHING THAT
WOULDN'T ALREADY BE OCCURRING
ARGUABLY HOMEOWNERS IN
PARTICULAR HAVE -- YOU KNOW
GREAT STAKE IN PROTECTING THEIR
HOMES FROM FIRE AND AT A COST OF
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS -- A 40% OF
WHICH WOULD COME OUT OF KIDS FOR
FOURTEEN AND WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS IMPACT ON THE GENERAL
FUND THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THAT OF THIS
CARIBBEAN AND WHAT I WOULD ALSO
NOTE IS BECAUSE EDUCATION
FUNDING HAS BEEN AN IN ADEQUATE --
FOR EXAMPLE OUR TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING IS FUNDED AT
200-082-0009 LEVELS AND THE
REASON THAT'S SIGNIFICANT IS OUR
EDUCATORS IN PARADISE WHO'S Là
WHO LOST THEIR SCHOOLS --
BECAUSE OF WHAT'S HAPPENED AND
THEY'RE HAVING TO TRANSPORT KIDS
FROM MADERA FROM CHICO FROM
GERMAN ANOTHER RATHER HAVE
NUMBER OF OTHER AREAS.
THEY'RE SPENDING -- DE TENDS
TIME MORE OF WHAT THEIR ACTUAL
TRANSPORTATION ALLOCATION IS
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
NOT ADEQUATELY FUNDED IN SO
FIRES ARE IMPACTING THEM AS WELL.
BUT IF YOU SUPPORT TAX CREDITS
THAN YOUR EDITION ONLY TAKING
MORE RESOURCES THAT COULD
OTHERWISE GO TO HELP OUR SCHOOLS
AND YOU COULD DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT THOSE THAT ARE ALSO BEING
HARMED BY FIRE FOR SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE DO A PULSE.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS IN THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE DOCTOR WOULD YOU
LIKE CLOSE.
IS SUCH WHICH IS A VERY OBVIOUS
SO IT IS SO VERY VERY COSTLY --
FROM ALL. FIVE YEARS OF PLANNING
HOMES -- AND ALSO -- INDUSTRY --
SO IS SARA.
A SMALL INVESTMENT OF FORCE TO
CONSIDER A TO SAVE LIVES IN THE
TO STRUCTURE I RESPECT BETH WE
ARE ABLE.
TO THANK YOU AYE WE'RE JUST KIND
OF WITH THE CALL ON A FEW ITEMS
REAL QUICKLY BETWEEN YOUR BILLS
MOVING FILE ITEM TEN AB ONE
FIFTY TO CALL THE ABSENTEES
CHILL.
OUR DAILY FILE ITEM. ONE AB
[inaudible]
ONE FIFTY TWO AND MELENDEZ.
MELINDA SORRY.
WE CAN COME BACK TO A FEELING OR
OKAY CAPITALISM THAT BILL IS OUT
MOVING TO FIND ITEM TWELVE AB.
TWO FIFTY ONE CALL THE ABSENTEES
[inaudible] TWO GRAY. TO NOT
VOTING.
GREAT MELENDEZ MULLIN THIS I
BETWEEN NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS THE DOUBLING
THAT'S BILLS BILLS OUT.
HELLO YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO
NUMBER. SIX OKAY OKAY OKAY WHAT
DO.
YOU CAN YOU WILL DO IT AT THE
END.
THE REST WERE TURNING BACK TO
TESTIMONY ON MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FOR AB TWELVE OH SIX DR TRY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN ON YOUR
ITEM.
TODAY MY NEXT BILL IS -- AB.
TWELVE FOUR SIX OUR TROUBLES SIX
IS OUT TO OFFER A TAX INCENTIVE.
ARE IN THE FORM OF A A TAX
CREDIT FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL OR
WALK.
A BUSINESS -- THAT RENTS SO WANT
ONE MORE UNITS -- BELOW MARKET
THE RATES UP TO A PERSON OR
PERSONS OF RECEIVING HOUSING
SERVICES TO WAR ASSISTANCE OF
FROM NON PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
CURRENTLY I MANY A NON PROFITS.
WAS THIS THE LOW SO WILL FIND
THEMSELVES SO WITHOUT THE
SHELTER WHILE HOUSING BY HELPING
TO FIND ACCOMMODATIONS SO THAT
THE FAMILY OR ONE INDIVIDUAL CAN
AFFORD.
TO MANY INDIVIDUALS SO AND THE
FAMILY IS THAT THE UTILIZED THE
ASSISTANCE OF THIS ON NON
PROFITS.
SO JUST -- HUMAN OPTIONS.
AND THE FAMILIES FORWARD.
OF VICTIMS OF ABUSE. TO INCLUDE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
DESERVE FAMILIES.
ARE FACING HOUSING IN SECURITIES
ARE WORKING WITH AND NON PROFITS.
OWN JOB PLACEMENT AND THE THE
AREAS OF ASSISTANCE SO THAT
THOUGHT THEY DO NOT THE BECOME
HOMELESS.
AND THE CAN CLIMB OUT OF THE
SITUATION THEY ARE CURRENTLY.
IN.
OFTEN THE A FAMILIES ARE IN NEED
THE WHOLE OF THE IS SELF WATER
BOARD UNIT SO ARE SINGLE MOTHERS.
WITH THE CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN
NOT THROUGH A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATIONS SO AND ARE SIMPLY
LOOKING FOR A SAFE PLACE TO CALL
HOME.
WITH THE ALMOST OF RECENT
REPORTS OF SHOWING THAT THE MORE
THAN ONE QUARTER OF THE NATION'S
CELL HOME NOW SO POPULATION.
THEY'VE SET IN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THE WE
PREVENT.
DION TOM WERE THE SPIRAL.
AND UP TO HELP OF THESE FAMILIES
ARE IN DANGER WILL BE COMING
HOMELESSNESS BY HELPING.
HELPING THEM FIND A HOUSING
OPTIONS SO THAT THEY CAN AFFORD.
THROUGH THIS ON NON PROFITS.
THE SIMPLE ACT OF A PROVIDING
HOUSING ALLOWANCE OF FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS IN THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES TO GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET.
RATHER THAN US BORROWED -- WORD
[inaudible]
AB ARE.
TROUBLE. SIX SIX TWO ALL FOR A
WIN WIN.
SOLUTION TO THIS OF PROPERTY
OWNERS.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO HELP THOSE IN
NEED?
AND TO TO THOSE OF FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SEEKING
ASSISTANCE SO. TO TO HARDSHIPS.
IN ADDITION BY INCENTIVIZING
PROPERTY OWNERS TOTAL RENT --
SOME OF THEIR UNITS ARE AT THE
COSTA ON THE MARKET RATES.
THIS BILL A LOT WILL PROVIDE THE
MORE INVENTORY.
OF A HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
THE FAMILIES THAT FIND
THEMSELVES IN THE OWN HOME AND I
SAW.
HOMELESSNESS OF SITUATION.
HOMELESS SITUATION.
THIS TAX INCENTIVE IS SUCH A
SMART INVESTMENT IN ORDER TO
REDUCE SO HOMELESS LESS.
IN.
OUR STATE AND HAS SO WIDESPREAD
SUPPORT BY BOTH THE VICTIMS
GROUPS ARE AND THE PROPERTY
ASSOCIATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN OUR STATE SO
EFFORTS TO SOLVE FOR
HOMELESSNESS.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE MANAGER KEEPS ON BEHALF OF
CALORIES BURNED.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
SEVERAL OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION I IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS
WRITTEN -- IT'S EXTREMELY
UNCLEAR AS TO THE SCOPE OF
POPULATION THAT WOULD THIS
NATURE -- WE DO BELIEVE THAT A
DIRECT ALLOCATION -- OR PERHAPS
EVEN AN INCREASE IN SOMETHING
LIKE RENTER'S CREDIT OR A GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WOULD MORE DIRECTLY
BENEFIT THE SPECIFIC POPULATIONS
OF WHICH MR CHOW SO ARTICULATELY
SPOKE WOULD BE MORE APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS IT'S
ACTUALLY SLATED TO GO TO OUR
CITY COUNCIL MEETING FOR AN
OFFICIAL POSITION -- AT OUR NEXT
MEETING -- BUT WE DO HAVE A A
STAFF OPPOSE RECOMMENDATION FOR
REASONS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
STATED BOB I SEE TRA AND WHILE
WE THINK THAT IT IS MERITORIOUS
WITH THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO
ACHIEVE BUT WE ARE ASKING FOR
ALTERNATE FUNDING MECHANISMS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE DOCTOR QUIRK --
SO I'M AFRAID I AGREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND BOTH OF YOUR
BILLS BUT THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
ISSUE.
THAT WASN'T MENTIONED.
AND THAT IS -- ACCORDING TO THE
ANALYSIS -- IT IS LIKELY THAT IF
WANT SOMEONE WERE TO TAKE THE
STATE TAX BENEFITS -- THAT THEY
WOULD -- NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE
DEPRECIATION OTHER FEDERAL
BENEFITS SO COULD END UP COSTING
SOMEONE MONEY.
RATHER THAN -- ENCOURAGING IT SO
I SUGGEST YOU -- I TALKED TO
SOME -- PERHAPS -- LEGAL EXPERTS
AT THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND
FIND OUT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS -- AN ISSUE TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THANK YOU.
A SCENE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE DOCTOR
TRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU AGAIN CHOICE HAS A
VERY CLEAR WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
THERE ARE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE -- WHO
CANNOT AFFORD A MARKET TO RATE
AND THAT THIS IS A WAY OF --
PROVIDING MORE AFFORDABLE HOMES.
IT COSTS MONEY AND THE PART THAT
THIS IS A WIN WIN SITUATION.
ARE THE ALL PROPERTY OWNERS SO --
CAN OFFER -- AND BELOW MARKET
RATES AND DOCKED AT THE TAX
INCENTIVES -- DOCILE ONE WAY
AMONG MANY OTHER WAYS SO WHILE
IT THOUGH WE ARE NOT CONTINUE
WITHOUT ANY ARE -- THOUGH HUESO
WE WE CAN FIND A SOLUTION AS TO
WHY IGNORE.
SINGLE I ASK FOR YARD.
THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONIAL A
TODAY SO THERE'S NO ACTION TODAY
THANK YOU.
DURING THE FILE ITEM
[inaudible] THREE AB.
THREE SIXTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA CONSISTENTLY IS A
LEADER IN THE NATION IN TERMS OF
ECONOMIC VALUE TALLY AND
INNOVATION AND THIS BILL AB.
THREE SIXTY FOUR WOULD EXEMPT
PASSED THROUGH BUSINESSES FROM
PAYING THE MINIMUM ANNUAL TAX
FOR THEIR FIRST YEAR OF
OPERATION.
THIS IS THE SAME EXEMPTION
PROVIDED TO NEW CORPORATIONS
DURING THE FIRST YEAR OF OPERATE
FIRST OPERATING YEAR.
CURRENTLY THE STATE IMPOSES AN
ANNUAL MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX OF
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS ON
BUSINESSES THAT OPERATE WITHIN
ITS BORDERS WHILE ALL
CORPORATIONS ARE EXEMPT FROM THE
TAX WITHIN THEIR FIRST YEAR OF
OPERATION.
PASTOR BUSINESSES A STRUGGLE
WITH CASH FLOW ARE NOT AFFORDED
THE SAME EXEMPTION.
WE NEED LONG TERM OR PERMANENT
SOLUTIONS TO INCENTIVIZE NEW
BUSINESSES THIS BILL WILL WORK
TO IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS
CLIMATE.
AND MAKE IT EASIER FOR
BUSINESSES AND ENTREPRENEURS TO
REMAIN.
COMPETITIVE AS A CALIFORNIA
BASED BUSINESS IN THIS GLOBAL
ECONOMY EXEMPTING NEW SMALL
BUSINESSES FROM HAVING TO PAY
THEIR FIRST MINIMUM ANNUAL TAX
WILL BE A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
IN A LEVY A IN THE COST
RESTRAINTS NEW BUSINESSES FACE
DURING THEIR FIRST YEAR
OPERATING WHEN I CAME UP HERE I
WORKED ON A BILL -- THEY HAD TO
DO A SMALL BUSINESSES I MET WITH
A BUNCH OF ENTREPRENEURS AND I
ASKED HIM IF THERE'S ONE THING
IF YOU COULD JUST WRITE YOUR OWN
LAW TO CHANGE ONE THING WHAT
WOULD IT BE AND WOULD BE A
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
EVERY YEAR THAT THEY GOT TO PAY
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING OR WITH THE
FIRST YEAR THAT THEY GOT A PAY
TO TO GET STARTED AND I SAID SO.
YOU CAN GET RID OF ANY
REGULATION YOU COULD DO ANYTHING
ELSE THIS THE ONE THING YOU DO
IS A GAP BECAUSE CASH FLOW MIGHT
SOUND LIKE A SMALL AMOUNT HE HAD
A DOLLARS ACTUALLY REALLY
MATTERS TO A SUMMER'S GETTING
STARTED.
AS A NEW BUSINESS SO -- I IT'S
IS THIS IS -- THE RIGHT A GOOD
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVE VOTE
WHEN THIS BILL IS UP FOR
CONSIDERATION FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE CALLING THE QUESTION FOR
THE COMMITTEE.
START QUIRK.
SO THE INTENTION HERE IS WHAT
TYPE OF CORPORATION YOU SAID
PASSED THROUGH CORPORATIONS
SMALL BUSINESSES SO RIGHT NOW IF
YOU'RE CORPORATION YOUR FIRST
YEAR'S EXAM I WANT.
TO I WANT TO ALSO ALLOW SMALL
BUSINESSES THE SAME EXEMPTION OF
THE HUNDRED DOLLARS OR SO WHAT
IT DOES IN THE ANALYSIS IS THAT
THEY COULD JUST DO A SOLE
PROPRIETORSHIP.
AND WE SEE THIS FOR ALL OF THESE
TYPES OF BILLS SET DO A SOLE
PROPRIETORSHIP.
THAT BY HAVING A LIMITED
LIABILITY CORPORATION -- OR A
LIMITED PARTNERSHIP THEY'RE
GETTING THE SPECIAL BENEFIT --
TO BASICALLY SHIELDING THEIR
PERSONAL.
WEALTH AND THEREFORE -- THERE IS
REASON TO CHARGE ADDITIONALLY --
PERHAPS YOU COULD TO ADDRESS
THAT.
OUR WELL AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED
YOU KNOW.
MAYBE I COULD COME BACK TO YOU
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SHIELDING
OF WEALTH THAT'S NOT MY
INTERPRETATION THE INTENT HERE
IS THE FOCUS ON ANYBODY.
THAT HAS YOU KNOW IF WE'RE GONNA
FORD AND AN EXEMPTION FROM UP
FOR CORPORATION ORDER TO WAIVE
THE FIRST YEAR OF A HUNDRED
DOLLARS I THINK THAT THERE ANY
PASTOR BUSINESS OR ANY OTHER
SMALL BUSINESS.
SHOULD BE AFFORDED THAT SAME
ABILITY -- UNDER OUR LAWS.
THANK YOU.
I GET A CHECK.
A MISTER CALDERON I JUST WANT TO
COMPLIMENT SHE EVEN FOCUS ON
THIS MINIMUM TAX SINCE YOU'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE YOU'VE
GOT SEVERAL ITERATIONS OF THIS
BUT I LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS A
CO AUTHOR I LOOK FOR TO VOTING
IN FAVOR OF IT WHEN IT COMES UP.
FOR ABOUT THE GIVES BIRTH.
IN THE MARKET TO ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK ON THE
SIDE OF SEEING NONE WOULD YOU
LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FREE TIME
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
I AM NOT GOING.
MEMBERS WILL DO ADD ONS RIGHT
NOW.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B..
SEVEN TWENTY THREE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
TO I GRAY.
GRAY EYED TREE NORRIS.
BETWEEN NORTH AYE TEAM.
TING NOT VOTING [inaudible]
START WITH.
THEY'RE ALL OUT WE'RE JUST DOING
ADAMS -- FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINE AB THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
TO CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE PETRIE NORRIS.
BUT YOU NORTH I TING
[inaudible]
TING I FILE ITEM TEN AB ONE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
TO CHIU I GRAY.
GRAY AYE PETRIE NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I TING
[inaudible]
TING NOW.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWO THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS
CHILL.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY I COUNTRY NORRIS.
TING [inaudible]
TING I TO OPEN.
HAS FALLEN TWELVE AB TWO FIFTY
ONE PLEASE CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAY I TING [inaudible]
TEAM NOW.
FILE I'M THIRTEEN AB TWO EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
TO CHILL I GRAY.
GRAY I HAD THREE NORRIS TING
[inaudible]
TING I FILE I'M FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE OH EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
TO CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY YE COUNTRY NORRIS TING.
TING NOW.
FILE I'M FIFTEEN AB THREE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
TO CHIU NOT VOTING GRAY.
GREAT I HAVE THREE NORRIS TING
[inaudible]
TING NOW.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX OH
EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. TO CHIU AYE GRAY.
GREAT I PATRICK NORRIS TING
[inaudible]
TING HI.
BOTTOM SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX
FOURTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
TO CHIU AYE GRAY.
GREAT I HAD TO NORRIS TANG
[inaudible]
TING HI.
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB SEVEN
THIRTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
TO CHIU AYE GRAY.
I PATRICK NORRIS KING
[inaudible]
TING ARE.
FOLLOW NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY TO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
TO CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY EYED COUNTRY NORRIS.
TING.
TING NOT VOTING FIVE TWENTY AB
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. TO TO OUR GRAY.
GRAY ISLANDERS -- GOT HER.
TING [inaudible]
TING I'D [inaudible]
OKAY -- WELL I YES ARE YOU
BELIEVE SHE IS -- PROBABLY
SOMEWHERE [inaudible]
COMING BACK [inaudible]
SH YEAH -- I KNOW SHE'S GOT
WITNESSES HERE.
WE'RE GONNA WAIT ON WE HAVE ONE
MORE ITEM FILE ITEM SIX BY MADAM
CHAIR WE'RE GONNA WAIT ON HER.
UNTIL SHE GETS BACK WILL TAKE A
LITTLE BREAK [inaudible]
THANK YOU
BY MADAM CHAIR
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN
REDUCES GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND INCREASES ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
ACROSS THE STATE PROVIDING A TAX
CREDIT TO IMPROVE OUR SHORTLINE
RAILROAD INFRASTRUCTURE.
A SHORT LINE RAILROAD IS A SMALL
OR MIDSIZE RAILROAD COMPANY THAT
OPERATES OVER RELATIVELY SHORT
DISTANCE COMPARED TO LARGER
NATIONAL ROAD NETWORKS.
YOU CAN THINK OF A SHORTLINE
RAILROAD AS THE FIRST AND LAST
MY LOVE A TRIP.
BECAUSE TRAINS ARE THE THREE TO
FIVE TIMES MORE FUEL EFFICIENT
THAN TRUCKS.
CONNECTING FREIGHT TO REAL
REDUCES BOTTLENECK IN
CONJUNCTION CONGESTION AND
RESULT IN LESS WEAR AND TEAR ON
OUR ROADS AND HIGHWAYS WHICH CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
IMPROVING SHORT LINE
INFRASTRUCTURE ALSO INCREASES
LOCALIZE AND STATEWIDE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS. FOR SHORT LINE
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTAINS
CALIFORNIA'S POSITION AS A
GLOBAL LEADER IN COMPETITOR FOR
GOODS MOVEMENT SECOND CHARLAINE
RAILROADS.
ALSO ALLOW CONTINUED ACCESS TO
RULE PARTS OF THE STATE ENSURING
THAT THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES
CONTINUE TO ADD JOBS AND
INCREASE ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN WILL
KEEP CALIFORNIA COMPETITIVE BY
INCENTIVIZE INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE ABOVE AND BEYOND
CURRENT MAINTENANCE SCHEDULES.
I HAVE HERE WITH US THE
ASSISTANT VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR JANICE IN
WYOMING HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME YOUR
QUESTION I THOUGHT.
WITH THIS SPORT I MISTER VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS JEFF AND SHAKEN AND
THE AB PEOPLE REFERS FOR JANICE
IN WYOMING IN OUR SIX SHORT LINE
RAILROADS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN IN
CALIFORNIA SHORELINES OPERATE
25% OF THE TRACK BUT ONLY MOVE
IT 11% OF THE FREE TRAFFIC.
THE SHORELINES EXIST TO SERVE
PARTS OF THE STATE WERE TRACK
WAS HELD BY PREVIOUS OWNERS BUT
SPUN OFF DUE TO LACK OF
INVESTMENT.
AND LACK OF CUSTOMER VOLUME AS A
RESULT THE SPINE OFF ASSETS
SUFFERED FROM YEARS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IN AN ACTIVE
MARKETING.
SURELY COMPANIES LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA NORTHERN RAILROAD
BODIES UNDERPERFORMING BRANCH
LINES TO REVITALIZE THEM ALONG
RURAL CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES IN
CUSTOMER SERVICE QUALITY GRAIN
AND AND C. P. WEST TO MAINTAIN
ACCESS TO THE NATIONAL FOR A
REAL NETWORK.
THE CALIFORNIA RIGHT STATE RAIL
PLAN SAYS IT BEST ON PAGE ONE
SEVENTY AND I QUOTE.
THE PRINCIPLE CHALLENGE THAT
MUST BE ADDRESSES THAT SOME OF
THE STATE SHORT LINE TRACKAGE
CANNOT HANDLE FREIGHT CARS WING
TO HURRY SIX THOUSAND POUND A
STANDARD THAT CLASS ONE
RAILROADS ADOPTED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR WERE LINE
IS NOT TO EIGHTY SIX K. CAPABLE
THE COMMON PRACTICE IS TO EITHER
LOAD A RAIL CAR TO LESS THAN ITS
MAXIMUM CAPACITY OR TO TRANSFER
THE LOADED TRUCKS FOR TRANSPORT
TO LOCATION WHERE THE RAILROAD
CAN HANDLE THE HEAVIER LOAD.
BOTH PRACTICES UNNECESSARILY
INCREASE COSTS THROUGH THE
INEFFICIENT USE OF ASSETS THE
ADDITIONAL STEPS REQUIRED AND
THE INCREASE TRAVEL TIME AND
QUOTE. THIRTY THREE OTHER STATES
PROVIDE PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY TO
HELP SMALLER FREIGHT RAILROAD
INFRASTRUCTURE CALIFORNIA'S
NOTICEABLY ABSENT FROM THAT LIST.
THE PUBLIC BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIA IN CREATING A PROGRAM
THROUGH THE PROPOSED SHORELINE
TAX CREDIT ARE CLEAR.
IMPROVED AIR QUALITY THROUGH
FEWER TRUCKS IN CALIFORNIA
ROADWAYS.
FEWER TRUCKS RESULT IN LESS
ROADWAY CONGESTION AND IMPROVE
HIGHWAY SAFETY.
THE BILL WAS SUPPORTED DIVERSE
BASE OF AGRICULTURE
MANUFACTURING SECTORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ECONOMY THAT
NEED SHORT LINE RAILROADS TO
REACH THEIR CUSTOMERS OR
SUPPLIERS EFFICIENTLY.
AND IT WILL IMPROVE
TRANSPORTATION CONNECTIVITY TO
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT ARE
OFTEN RURAL AND WITH FEWER
OPTIONS FOR GOODS MOVEMENT.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU INITIAL
AND THIS IS A SUPPORT.
IS A GERMAN MEMBERS MIKE
ANDERSON WITH THE SMART
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION FORMALLY
UNITED TRANSPORTATION UNION.
AND WE REPRESENT THE OPERATING
EMPLOYEES ON MANY SHORT LINES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
WILL RESULT IN ENHANCE RAILROAD
SAFETY. FOR OUR MEMBERS
EMPLOYEES AND FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC AS WELL SO WE'RE IN
SUPPORT.
SHOW AND THIS IS IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NON MEMBERS COMMITTEE ANYONE
WISHING ASK ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE MADAM CHAIR WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE.
WHEN IT IS THE APPROPRIATE TIME
I WOULD APPRECIATE THE COMMUNITY?
OUR SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] NINE
THREE NORRIS.
AB -- TWO THIRTY FOUR YEAH
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS I NUMBER THIRTEEN
AB. TWO EIGHTY SIX FIVE THREE
NORTH I ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE OH EIGHT PETRIE NORRIS.
DID I HEAR AYE OKAY.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB THREE TWENTY ONE
VETERAN NORRIS [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS I I AM SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SIX OH EIGHT THREE NORRIS
[inaudible]
IT IS.
I AM SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX
FOURTEEN PETRIE NORRIS.
BETWEEN OURS I ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
SEVEN THREE SIX PETRIE-NORRIS.
BUT YOU NORTH I ITEM NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THREE TWO COUNTRY
NORRIS [inaudible]
YES -- THAT YEAH. THREE NORTH
NOT VOTING ON AB.
EIGHT THREE TWO AND THE LAST
BILL ITEM TWENTY AB -- EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE AND I ALREADY HAVE
THE VOTING [inaudible]
THE SINGLE DOES.
I HAVE YOU ON SEVENTY THREE YEAH.
YES THEY DO.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A CONSENT.
BUT WE KIND OF WENT BACK AND
FORTH